rock fans were devastated to learn on
october 6
2020 that eddie van halen had passed
away at 65 years of age
following what his son wolfgang van
halen described on twitter as
a long and arduous battle with cancer
over a career spanning several decades
eddie van halen helped revitalize the
hard rock genre
inspired a generation of music lovers
and contributed to numerous memorable
moments in pop culture history
that often extended beyond the scope of
the musical stage putting aside the
timeless songs co-wrote and performed
with his namesake band
eddie van halen performed the classic
guitar solo on michael jackson's beat it
had a voice cameo on frasier and was
immortalized as a stop-motion rock and
roll hamburger
in 1985's better off dead that same year
the rockstar made another more obscure
addition to the world of cinema
when he was included in back to the
future director robert zamekis's sci-fi
adventure flick that made michael j
fox a household name made everyone
realize who really invented rock and
roll
and made hundreds of millions of dollars
at the box office however van halen's
quote unquote appearance in back to the
future was so subtle
and unconventional that it may have
stuck right by you in case you're rusty
the scene in question shows franchise
protagonist from arty mcfly
sneaking into his then teenage father's
room in the middle of the night circa
1955
hoping to scare him into action with
some science fiction skullduggery
dressed in a hazmat suit marty places a
pair of headphones over his sleeping
dad's ears then puts a cassette tape
into his walkman
the tape is labeled edward van halen and
the accompanying electric guitar wailing
that blasts out when marty presses play
and wakes his father certainly lives up
to the name
[Applause]
when the elder mcfly asks him who he is
marty quickly responds
silence earthling then he answers and
says his name is darth vader
for years after back to the future's
release fans wondered whether the real
eddie van halen played the music heard
on the edward van halen cassette tape
speaking in an on-the-fly interview with
tmz in 2012
van halen confirmed that it's true those
are his awesome 80s guitar riffs you
hear in back to the future
the guitar legend never made a big deal
about his contribution to the iconic
film
he called the recording just a bunch of
noise which to be fair
it is but it's still one of those fun
back to the future details
that are hard not to love while he
didn't provide the guitar track for
johnny b
good that was guitarist tim may or kick
in on the songs by huey lewis and the
news
van halen did indeed play a part in
exploding the eardrums of crisping
glover's young george mcfly
and that deserves some serious applause
in its own right eddie van halen wasn't
the only rock star to make a subtle
appearance in back to the future
huey lewis of huey lewis on the news
appears as a judge when marty's group
auditions for his school's battle of the
band's competition
unfortunately huey has some harsh
criticism for the group
i'm afraid then there's flea
the long time basis for the red hot
chili peppers he shows up in both back
to the future sequels
as marty's longtime frenemy needles in a
less subtle cameo
zz top performs drawing part 3 playing
the 1885 hill valley fair
a young elijah wood also appeared as a
kid trying to play an old arcade game in
part 2
but that wouldn't exactly count as a
celebrity easter egg unless you had some
kind of time machine
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
great movie cameos are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one